hey everybody welcome back to elemental
gardens today with no intro for the
video or at least no cinematic shots
which is something that hasn't happened
in a super long time some kind of bummed
out about that I definitely should have
had something in there would have at
least made the entry in this video a
little bit nicer than just suddenly
hearing my voice out of the blue but to
be honest I made a lot of these videos
under tremendous time pressure in an
already kind of busy week and doing
everything on the fly in one batch and
now I'm going through all of the
commentaries day by day in one batch as
well so it's it's not really my usual
kind of production schedule it's much
much tighter than what I normally do so
I hope you'll excuse me for being a
little bit messy in this I'm actually
very glad that I've been able to finish
this schedule and keep it on schedule
and finish this thing on time but anyway
what are we doing today I'll be working
on one point of the Main Street or I
guess actually the majority of the Main
Street finishing this one building on
this side so that we can move over to
the other side get all the buildings in
there and that basically means that the
Main Street is going to be finished
after this episode also I'll be working
on a small vault sort of small a pretty
large actually entrance Plaza that
you'll come into after the Main Street
because there was still an open area
between the Main Street and the
observation tower and I originally
thought that I could put the PAC's logo
on that observation or on that Plaza
next to the observation tower but it
turned out that putting a logo inside a
square that's at the end of the Main
Street would kind of block the view that
I would or might otherwise normally have
so in the end I decided to make the logo
on the entrance building so that's
something that I'll get through in a
little bit
first though I wanted to finish this
corner building and this is kind of
interesting because it's a very
different spelling on them when I have
so far in the park or at least I guess
it still kind of fits in it's a bit of
an art deco streamline Moderne building
which is a little bit more old-fashioned
what I have so far definitely a bit more
old fashioned than the contemporary
architecture which I have in here but
it's a very quick little experimentation
that I figured I might as well try
because I wanted to have a corner
building which would still be
interesting but at the other hand not
used to many details and also be
something that I could build relatively
quickly so I ended up going for this
sort of streamline Moderne style since
is something that you can do quite
quickly it doesn't take too many details
and it was quite simple to design just
some windows and some of those
horizontal actions and the curving
corners that make that type of Art Deco
building so typical so that's something
I wanted to get into the corner there
not really much else to it just a corner
building to neatly wrap up that side of
the Main Street and after that I wanted
to do a little bit of class works get an
idea of what the entire path is going to
look like also mess up a little bit with
like a little checkerboard pattern on
the path on the entrance and something
that I've never really done before but
you can actually make some pretty good
patterns if you like keep a very small
grid on your path and in this case it
seems the entire Main Street is built on
a grid it's something that I could try
and I figured might as well try it and
see what it looks like and I think it
looks a little bit more interesting than
just keeping one single simple part
texture and it's definitely not
something that I would do everywhere
throughout the park especially
realistically seeing that past's inside
theme parks are usually just super
boring and very often just concrete and
in a game like this where all of the
pumps are very heavily textured and
coloured they are already quite a bit
fancier than inside real life theme
parks and I quite honestly wouldn't want
to start making out too many patterns
throughout the products there aren't
that many amusement parks that really
have colorful patterns on their part
works and if they do it's either very
broad patterns that you can only really
distinguish on a map or it's very small
little arty pieces
anyway after I did that I sort of got a
general layout in I wanted to work on
the logo on the entrance of the and the
entrance of the park and this is
something that I talked about very
quickly in the last episode because we
were tasked to include a logo somewhere
in the park so that there is some kind
of reference to tax and I figured
because putting the logo on like
someplace in the middle of the park as a
centerpiece would kind of be awkward I
also have the problem that it's nearly
impossible to make a logo that like you
can make out as the logo from multiple
angles and obviously if it's the center
piece you're going to have to make it be
able to be looked at from multiple
angles and for that reason putting it on
the front of the park just on top of the
entrance as you're getting into the park
it's the only way that you can make sure
that people are actually approaching it
from the right angle the other sort of
thing that I was considering was making
a structure that would look like a P if
you look at it from one angle would look
like an A if you look at it from one
angle and would look like an X if you
look at it from another angle and well
that's technically possible and maybe
someday somebody is going to try
something crazy like that there was no
way that I had time to like calculate
how to even begin thinking about such a
thing so I just ended up going for the
most obvious probably the easiest and
perhaps also just the best way to go
about doing it and putting it on top of
the entrance kind of like you would
often want to have on a theme park
you're just being raided by what the
theme park is actually about and very
quickly I also figured I could make some
planters and this is where I ran into
some scaling problems you might also
notice it for the rest of the building
the in-game grid and it's just the
in-game scaling of the walls for
instance is a little bit iffy in a sense
that it's quite large we've got four
meter high walls but obviously very
often I end up building buildings out of
a wall plus a flat roof piece making
floors that are about four to five
meters tall and that is
quite out of skill especially when you
consider that with forced perspective in
a theme Clark in the mainstream you kind
of want to make the upper floors even
smaller than that so there is already
kind of a scaling problem going on in
the main street in the sense that
everything's a little bit too large you
only really notice it when peeps are
standing right beside a building but
it's still a little bit horse and I kind
of felt that with the planters that I
was trying for a while as well so I
wanted to make sure that those things
were at least small enough so that they
wouldn't really stand now it's beside
the guest now moving back again to the
square
I had no planning whatsoever when I was
laying out this episode just kind of
working on whatever I had some ideas for
I reckoned that I could actually just
put some hedges along the side of the
square I know it's pretty boring and
it's not the most imaginative thing but
the problem is that a lot of this area
is just going to end up being quite
empty for one because I didn't have that
much time to finish the park so I
couldn't really make a square surrounded
by buildings like I would have done in
fantasy Valley and also there are many
empty spaces because I need the empty
spaces in the point for people to build
in so I figured in the end if I'm not
going to have that much foliage around
this square it's going to end up looking
like a very desolate and sort of open
agoraphobia ish place that you don't
have and I figured I could at least
close it a bit make it a bit more
comfortable by putting a lot of foliage
on the square itself hence the hedges
and some of the foliage that I'll be
filling in alongside the square with
some planters and some foliage that'll
sit inside of these little hedged of
areas I still just love the way that the
hedges look with the grass and the way
you can actually very neatly like make
some shapes along side paths and kind of
make some grassy areas that are tiled in
between path areas like that it can be
very time consuming to get the shapes of
the hedges in correctly so my tip would
be to
build hedges within one building
whenever you're doing it so that you can
save your shapes and copy/paste them
around kind of like I did with these
hedges and I can definitely save you a
lot of time especially if you can make
some very standard modules like a 45
degree corner hedge piece or just a
straight edge piece and be able to glue
those pre-made pieces together rather
than building the entire string of
hedges yourself out of individual hedge
scenery item so that's why did with that
and here I kind of worked on doing some
part elements on the side of the plants
and just taking some of the lanterns
that I made earlier on and copying these
things around which is quite a handy
thing if you've got them saved as a
separate building and making sure that
we actually have some pretty cool custom
lighting going on on that fence and this
is already done super quickly so it's
not the most detailed thing but I think
it does give a pretty good idea on how
you can actually can are you can
actually combine some different items
and games to make your own items and
save those around as if they were just
in game scenery objects now because the
corner building was looking a little bit
unfinished and I decided to add some
finishing touches to it and bring it to
life a little bit so we've got some
lights and then I was looking for a good
sign so put on top of the door but
almost every sign or is either too big
or too small
and in Ian I just kind of gave up on
that lamp and put some planters beside
the building a small antenna spire ish
thing on the top and that's it and
that's pretty much time to move into the
next building so this building again is
going to be a bit more like the stuff
that I've tried earlier but again I kind
of wanted to experiment a bit so my goal
for this building was to try and make a
very modern looking building that would
still fit inside the main street and not
make it a very cold desolate place but
at the same time a building in which I
try to avoid using windows as much as I
can because you might know there are no
actual fittings loss windows in the game
this is also a problem that I talked a
bit about in the last episode and so one
way that I guess you could try to
alleviate that problem is to just avoid
having windows in your building
altogether and that's kind of what I try
to do in this building it was a little
bit inspired by some designs of malls
and car dealerships in America which is
stupid as they are connection is a
pretty decent sometimes with the lack of
Windows and even worse and even more
American I guess a was also inspired by
some McDonald's designs like having
those those wooden blind strips and
decorations in a sense it's kind of
McDonald fish even though there are some
slight variations on the themes
throughout the buildings like for
instance these white pillars on the side
which kind of serves to make a blank
windowless war a bit more interesting
than just a blank windowless wall they
still do have some variation to them
like every pillow is a little bit
thicker than the pillar beside it so
there's some interesting place honest
it's not entirely just simple beams and
patterns but it's it's a very
contemporary building in that sense
trying to avoid those windows as much as
I can and I didn't feel too bad about it
like some part of me probably died
making a building that's inspired by
McDonald's and malls in America because
that's probably for this thing I've ever
done but at least it is actually you
know it's actually a burger joint it's
if the cheese bees believe so you know
we shouldn't worry about it too much I
guess this is actually kind of a fitting
theme I feel for the cheese beef
restaurant at least I think it's a
pretty good thing that they could go for
with their brand anyway I just quickly
built the little things on the bottom
there put achieve peace outside there to
greet all the guests make the Main
Street a little bit more exciting no of
course stuff like that is definitely
going to make your Main Street a bit
more exciting than not having anything
and finally I did want to put some
darker stuff on the bottom floor as
though I actually did have some
if decoration there and I wasn't
entirely sure how to approach these
windows in the end I did use some of the
ingame windows at the bottom there just
because they fit in and making my own
ones would take too many objects too
much time and these said anyway so I use
something else so I quickly put in some
glass from the bottom floor but the rest
of the building is staying pretty much
the way it is and I just wanted to put a
white outline around it to make it look
a bit more interesting than just a great
books and kind of take the very boxiness
away from it so I'm going with a basic
shape around here just kind of around
the gray box to make it all look a
little bit more interesting like it's
actually facing the front of the
mainstream and that more or less
finishes this building rest of the work
is really just finishing the back side
of it making sure that we actually do
have some kind of mass to the building
and that eventually I can actually hook
up to the large sort of backstage area
which I have behind all of these
buildings but anyway with that out of
the way I figured it was time to move
into the next thing and I think I
actually copied those windows from some
earlier buildings so I'm not entirely
sure anymore but the buildings which I
wanted to build here are a bit more like
I guess American row houses some very
old ones stuff that you would see around
Chicago but then in more of a new
urbanism kind of style so it's still
using some much more modern textures and
a bit more minimalistic detailing but
it's still very much the style that it's
trying to emulate in a very simple way
because I wanted to do this quite
quickly but it's also a style which I
didn't have in the main street yet so I
figured it might as well try it and see
how it ends up and especially when it
comes to like the frieze which I have on
the top of it or well it's technically
just the corners especially when it
comes to the cornices which I have on
top of the building I think that really
just makes or breaks the buildings in
these case and being able to make your
own
bonus pieces is something that really
adds especially to buildings like these
I've seen a few of these recently
actually in Plymouth coaster and the
ability to put all kinds of very small
scenery objects together - that was the
weirdest pronunciation of together I've
ever heard but you have to put like all
kinds of small scenery pieces together
to make your own corners pieces I think
its parts like that on buildings like
these that really make them different
and with which you can make every
building unique like the walls
themselves are just straight walls with
a simple texture and some windows on it
and there's really not anything else to
this building it's the shape and the
detail that the cornice is bringing out
it's really just about what does it for
these buildings I guess so with those
things finished I figured it was time to
move into the lighting for a little bit
you know I haven't really lit up any of
the Main Street this is where the area
life come back and they are really
important I put them on a sort of very
dark brown tint which is a gray brownish
which is a tone of colour which I really
like for the lights I think white is
very bright and you run a really great
risk at over lighting your buildings and
just going for this very dark round s
color as a subtle lighting to your
buildings as if they're actually being
lit up by real park spotlights but at
the same time it doesn't really over
light them and there's also a very
slight warm touch to it
like it's not exactly white which I was
afraid would make these buildings very
cold because many of these buildings
still do have some very rustic warm
colors to them so I wanted to bring that
out in the lighting as well so that's
why it's slightly Brown instead of being
white anyway to move into the next
building this is a bit of a filler a bit
more of a classical building actually
and just with some round windows and
some more classical details all still
very simple but I think it fits in quite
nicely with the
houses on the side which I just built
earlier so I figured I could get that in
there and it's also a pretty good
opening for what is that again the the
folksy coffee even though I don't think
it's cold anymore I'm entirely sure but
it's the coffee shop with a focus anyway
with the amazing design by SP Ridley as
well which is pretty cool for those who
didn't know it was actually a mascot
networks designed by a community member
SP Ridley and there were some contests
for people to draw and get their own
mascots out there and they've actually
been taken into the game which is pretty
pretty interesting stuff to know anyway
moving on to the next building and this
is the final building over the main
street another main street like modern
ish building I figured would work out
quite nicely over here since we're close
to the entrance and I wanted to get back
into the more entrance style at this
point and again I was trying to avoid
having that window texture as much as I
could by kind of having these detail
pillars on the front here but in the
back I did end up going with the in-game
windows again because I felt like the
texture just works
more or less fine and especially some of
the framework that you have on those
windows works quite nicely with the
textures that I had on the building so
far so I always quite happy with that
very simple building where really the
only touch to it is the detailing but I
think in the end it does work quite
nicely and I'm pretty happy with how it
rounds up all of the buildings in the
main street so to conclude this episode
I wanted to do a little bit of detailing
around the Main Street not too much but
still put some of those signs of life in
so some more planters some lights around
the buildings where I didn't have those
yet and basically make everything kind
of look as though it's actually you know
being lived at or being part of the
theme park and very finally get into the
foliage of the plaza here so we kind of
have an idea
that's going to look like and that is
pretty much it for today so thank you
guys for watching and I'll see you guys
in the next episode
[Music]